le dernier chapitre de la guerre froide
vraiment de scott ici tout à fait une
relique de la guerre froide en train de
s'effriter avec échange de prisonniers
c'est difficile de faire plus guerre
froide que ça une guerre froide qui a
continué malgré l'implosion de l'urss
uniquement parce que c'était
politiquement rentable de profiter de
l'opposition des groupes anticastristes
de miami
ensuite il ya eu des développements qui
ont avant coureur de ce dégel disons la
reconnaissance par les états unis des
efforts contre les mollahs des médecins
cubains et aussi ces négociations de la
colombie avec les farc à la havane qui
sont en train d'aboutir il ya un
cessez-le-feu illimité qui a été
déclarée décrété par les farc et puis
émet des changements surtout économique
à cuba qui sont quand même intéressant
alors ça fait des années que cette
situation empoisonne la planète entière
tous les ans ou nations unies on vote
contre l'embargo américain parce que ça
pénalise toutes les compagnies de tous
les pays du monde y compris le canada
donc on devra ajouter aboutir à
l'élimination de cet embargo qui coûte
très cher au cou la levée de l'embargo
c'est ce que souhaite gérald les cubains
parce qu'ils veulent oui rehausser leur
niveau de vie et pour us la grand grand
espoir quand même levé l'embargo c'est
difficile de dire combien ça a coûté
justement l'économie cubaine quelques
dizaines de milliards quelques centaines
de milliards de dollars selon
différentes sources ou au coeur de tout
ça il ya quand même 11 millions 11
millions de cubains qui espère justement
que leur niveau de vie que leur qualité
de vie va remonter malgré un pib par
habitant de 6500 $ puisqu'on est dans
une société qui a beaucoup investi dans
l'éducation et la santé l'espérance de
vie quand même de 79 ans taux
d'alphabétisme d'alphabétisation de 99%
et aujourd'hui le travailleur cubain
peut espérer peut-être profiter de
nouveaux investissements à cuba deux
sources financières plus grande d'un
coup avec l'augmentation des envois que
les américains pourront faire vers cuba
de 2000 à 8000 $ par année plus de
voyageurs américains et vous le voyez
les réserves de pétrole qui sont de 5 à
9 milliards selon les estimations
peut-être éventuellement on pourra
exploiter davantage le pétrole en mer
dans le golfe du mexique qui appartient
au territoire cubain à l'on parle de
cuba mais si les effets économiques sont
à plus grande échelle ça va tourner un
peu beaucoup d'autres pays notamment le
canada
parce qu'on vient lever la pression sur
toutes les entreprises et tous les pays
qui hésitent à aller à cuba et qui
hésitent à faire des affaires avec cuba
ouverture potentielle à des
investissements importants dans les
infrastructures notamment qui ont besoin
quand même d'être revue à cuba pour les
canadiens et des entreprises qui font
déjà des affaires à cuba on pense à
sherritt international qui la première
entreprise énergétique de cuba
étrangères et qui a mine de nickel
elle a gagné 26% aujourd'hui parce qu'on
voit justement l'effondrement de
certaines règles qui pourraient
faciliter les activités économiques
d'entreprises comme ça alors évidemment
on ses débuts n'est rapprochement est un
long processus vers quoi on s'en va à
quoi il faut s'attendre aux chênes
têtards et très vite l'ouverture d'une
ambassade à l'ouverture d'une ambassade
à cuba il en va commencer les
négociations pour les importations de
toutes sortes de produits et les
échanges surtout surveiller le 10 et 11
avril au panama et le sommet des
amériques les leaders latino américains
ont exigé la présence de raul castro
barack obama aujourd'hui a dit qu'il y
serait donc attendez vous un tête à tête
première étape à notre part à qu'obama
et raul castro 1 - d'une visite de
barack obama à cuba ce que la maison
blanche aujourd'hui n'a pas vraiment
écarté vraiment alors ça serait toute
une toute une étape quand même quelque
chose de très symbolique
merci beaucoup à vous non merci